[Music]
so this is magnesium metal but the
magnesium metal here it's not the ribbon
which we normally see in perhaps
scientific labs or perhaps in in school
labs this is a very very fine powder of
magnesium so what we're going to do in a
moment is we're going to bring on a
really really quite powerful torch a gas
flame and we're going to see what
happens when we sprinkle a little bit of
this material into the flame magnesium
is also a metal and it's very light and
so it is used for a number of
lightweight applications for example
it's used in alloy wheels for cars and
rather more prosaically it's used for
the body of pencil sharpeners so if you
look at the pencil sharpener like this
one the actual body is made out of
magnesium and the blade is made from
steel because that has to be sharp Anil
is going to bring in the flame that
you're going to get that turned up
okay so we're sprinkling a little bit of
the magnesium powder
and you can see the bright flashes of
white light as the magnesium burns in
the flame